mal à monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
de l'actualité de ce lundi 19 juillet
aux etats-unis il ya maintenant plus
d'espoir de retrouver des f-15 junior
son épouse et sa belle soeur encore en
vie les recherches se sont intensifiées
pour tenter de retrouver leurs corps
pendant que les drapeaux sont en berne à
hyannis port dans ce que l'on appelle le
clan kennedy au kosovo les ministres
européens créer une agence pour la
reconstruction de la province vers la
kouchner appelle lui la communauté
internationale à accélérer son aide
alors que la cohabitation entre serbes
et albanais s'annonce de plus en plus
improbable la contre attaque d'elle sur
total fina quinze jours après l'offre
publique d'achat lancée par total contre
elf
le groupe pétrolier réplique en
proposant à son tour d'absorber son
concurrent une opération de 300
milliards de francs et puis une enquête
sur la haute couture dans ce journal
alors qui est présenté en ce moment la
collection automne hiver
sophie mais elle nous dira à quoi sert
vraiment c'est fabuleux défilé à yanis
porte les premiers drapeaux ont été mis
aujourd'hui en berne les sauveteurs ont
annoncé qu'il n'avait quasiment plus
d'espoir de retrouver vivant john
fitzgerald kennedy junior son épouse
carolyn bessette et sa belle-soeur
lorraine il n'y avait à bord de
l'appareil que piloter john john kennedy
ni radeau de survie ni gilet de
sauvetage et l'eau est trop froide pour
y survivre plus de 18 heures marie ce
blog ce week end il devait se marier
mais rory kennedy et son fiancé non
évidemment plus le coeur à la fête
lorsque cette image a été filmée hier
soir à hyannisport ce qu'ils espéraient
encore depuis le clan kennedy a compris
que john john ne reviendrai plus
les télévisions américaines saisissent
de loin les étreintes d'une famille une
nouvelle fois éprouvée par le destin
pour l'instant les kennedy ne se sont
pas exprimés pas plus que leur porte
parole
ethel kennedy la veuve de robert kennedy
que l'on voit ici avec des lunettes
noires
c'est comme le reste du clan que ce sont
maintenant des corps sans vie est une
épave que les plongeurs recherchent deux
sites ont été repérés au large de
martha's vineyard
les détecteurs ont identifié des masses
au fond de l'océan le site où se trouve
la matière a repéré au sauna se trouvent
environ 10 800 pieds de reprendre parce
que nous pensons les enquêteurs pensent
qu'il pourrait s'agir de l'avion
accidenté ce soir à yanis porte on
commence à oser parler de l'imprudence
de john john kennedy pilotes peu
expérimentés ils volaient partant de
brume sans instrument de guidage des
considérations que bien sûr la dynastie
kennedy ne veut pas entendre pour
l'instant et déjà l'amérique pleurs
celui qu'elle considérait comme le
prince de sa famille royale les kennedy
elle pleure et s'interroge sur le sort
qui s'acharne sur cette famille et
stoppe brutalement la destinée d'un
homme de 38 ans sur place à yanis porte
le reportage de dominique baert à éric
perrin le nom évidemment inspire la
confiance
alors quand l'actualité vous rattrape
sur le lieu de vos vacances et que le
monde soudain braquent sur un petit port
du massachusetts et projecteurs ces
caméras et micros
pourquoi ne pas aller y voir d'un peu
plus près pour à peine 10 $ une
quinzaine de fois par jour prudence et
patience les deux navires de la
compagnie conduisent à faible allure
leurs passagers de tous âges au large de
la résidence d'été des kennedy
il ya beaucoup d'activités au monde dans
le secteur après ce qui est arrivé et on
pense tout ça ça nous sommes très
curieux de voir où ça arrive la maison
mais plus encore que les riches demeures
le clou de la croisière c'est cet
immense chapiteau sous lequel on devait
fêter samedi dernier le mariage de rory
la cousine de john kennedy junior en
regardant de ce côté tout le monde est
resté silencieux
je crois qu'on pensait tous la même
chose
le recueillement à distance respectueuse
moi j'ai toujours rêvé qu'il se lance
dans la politique comme son père il
n'avait pas l'air de vouloir le faire
pour le moment et on dirait bien
maintenant que c'est trop tard
un espoir qui peu à peu s'est amenuisé
au fil des marées et des courants qui le
long des côtes atlantiques balaye les
fonds marins c'est assez effrayant qu'on
pourrait croiser quelque chose j'espère
qu'ils sont entre les mains de dieu
manon ce n'ont pas survécu
avant même que l'on annonce qu'il était
désormais trop tard pour croire encore
au miracle
ils sont venus en pèlerinage comme s'il
savait déjà sans oser se l'avouer que
tout espoir était perdue dominèrent
dabon soir vous êtes sur place alors y
at il des dernières nouvelles sur l'état
des recherches actuellement
écoutez les recherches se poursuivent
évidemment deux équipes de plongeurs
sont en train d'essayer de déterminer si
les les objets comme on dit ici si les
objets repérés au fond de la mer par le
sonar sont bien des débris de l'appareil
ou si ce sont comme ce sont des rochers
par exemple comme ce pourrait être le
cas vous savez les sonars fournissent
une image qui ressemble un peu à l'image
d'une échographie
c'est pas extrêmement précis et dans ce
cas là eh bien il faut envoyer des
plongeurs pour déterminer si c'est bien
si ce sont bien des des morceaux de
l'affût du car dont des morceaux du
fuselage de la carlingue de l'appareil
si c'était le cas et bien ensuite il
faudrait voir s'il ya des corps à
l'intérieur est ensuite remonté ces
corps vu la taille des débris qui ont
été retrouvées on imagine que l'appareil
doit être doit être en très très mauvais
état car les débris sont très petit et
indique donc que le choc au moment où
l'appareil a touché la mère a dû être
extrêmement brutale alors dominique
maintenant du côté du clan kennedy est
ce qu'on sait déjà si une cérémonie est
envisagée pour rendre hommage à l'
héritier disparu
on sait que les kennedy réfléchisse à
une cérémonie il y avait une rumeur ce
matin qui disait que à la cathédrale
saint patrick à new york dans quelques
jours il pourrait y pourrait y avoir un
service religieux
or cette rumeur pour l'instant n'est pas
confirmé les kennedy ce sont le clan
kennedy qui était très nombreux et
qu'ils étaient réunis ce week-end pour
le mariage de rory la cousine de la
cousine de jake et juniors et bien bonne
bon nombre des membres de la famille
sont repartis dès hier d'autres ce matin
dont le sénateur ted kennedy qui est
repartie d'ici ce matin les membres
restants autour des pelles la mer là
pardon eiffel qui étaient là qui est la
veuve de robert kennedy le
les membres restants se sont réunis ce
matin pour une nouvelle prière mais on
ignore encore à quel moment ils feront
un communiqué hans attend ici à ce qu'il
est il ce qu'ils émettent un communiqué
probablement dans la journée peut être
demain mais pour l'instant encore aucune
information précise à ce sujet merci à
dominique toute la presse à travers le
monde et bien sûr aux états unis rend
hommage à john kennedy junior l'icône
d'un pays le prince américain
l'incarnation des rêves les plus beaux
autant de titres qui montre bien sûr la
sincère émotion du peuple américain tout
le monde se souvient du petit garçon de
3 ans qui faisait le salut militaire
devant la dépouille de son père
assassiné en 63 à new york
pascal d'où ces bandes c'est désormais
une habitude la une du magazine de john
kennedy junior trône au beau milieu de
broadway journal à la fois branchée et
populaire à l'image de tribeca quartier
où le couple vivait dans un loft tout en
haut de cet immeuble
robert de niro et harvey keitel habitat
de pain tout le monde à manhattan
connaissent l adresse alors les fleurs
ont vite envahi le trottoir les
témoignages sont laïcs ou religieux
sobre ou passionnés elle dit lui avoir
écrit qui lui manquerait et qu'elle
pense à sa famille et sa mère ajoute
qu'à 15 ans sa fille vit là un jour
inoubliable
l'absence de nuances et le mausolée
improvisé rappelle une autre idole
diana est d'ailleurs ici la comparaison
est dans toutes les têtes
bien sûr dit cet homme les deux
personnages étaient largement comparable
et l'émotion qu'il génère aujourd'hui
est la même
lui avoue qu'il rêvait au style de vie à
l'appartement est et à la réussite du
couple le plus glamour à manhattan
le thème du dernier éditorial de john
john lui allait comme un gant
il y évoquait le retour du rêve
américain un rêve américain dont chacun
s'accorde ici à dire qu'il incarnait à
merveille un nouveau charnier découvert
au kosovo cette fois c'est dans le nord
de la province à la frontière avec la
serbie dans le village de podujevo là
les enquêteurs du tribunal international
de la haye ont découvert une fosse
contenant score d'une même famille parmi
eux se trouverait quatre enfants chaque
jour presque de nouvelles traces sont
ainsi découverte des exactions commises
par les serbes au kosovo aujourd'hui les
ministres européens des affaires
étrangères se sont entendus pour créer
une agence européenne pour la
reconstruction du kosovo mais bernard
kouchner de son côté demande à la
communauté internationale d'accélérer
son aide l'urgence dit il c'est la
protection et la sécurité entre serbes
et albanais leur cohabitation paraît de
plus en plus impossible comme le montre
ce reportage agnès vahramian et de
nathalie gallet à la mairie de christina
là on essaye envers et contre tous de
les faire travailler ensemble devant la
mairie les deux groupes ne se mélangent
pas serbe d'un côté albanais de l'autre
le plus facile pour l'onu a été de
mettre tout le monde d'accord sur de
nouvelles listes d'employés les serbes
n'avaient de toute façon pas le choix
hier majoritaires ils ne sont plus que
60 employés de mairie à vivre à pristina
les autres ont fui à guillaume
l'albanais travaillait aux finances de
la ville il y a dix ans puis il a été
licencié
certains de ses collègues ont quitté la
mairie par solidarité aujourd'hui à
guînes fait preuve de bonne volonté il
dit avoir recensé tous les albanais et
les serbes afin que chacun touche ça
paye côté albanais la vie s'organise à
la mairie
les serbes eux entreront les derniers
aucun ne se déplace seul même à
l'intérieur du bâtiment à guimps dans
les sous-sols nous indique comment la
sécurité civile serbe avait stocké de
l'armement et caisses vides qu'elle a
laissées après sa défaite
ce matin les employés serbes sont
inquiets pour leur sécurité ils veulent
en discuter à l'écart devant la porte
cet employé qui a toujours travaillé ici
explique que les albanais comme elle
était confinée à des emplois subalternes
et que si ses collègues s'enferme c'est
qu'ils ont quelque chose à se reprocher
dans ce climat délétère il y en a
pourtant qu'ils se parlent délégués par
les serbes cet homme en chemise blanche
explique un albanais qu'il y a eu des
intimidations et quatre agressions
d'employés pas ici mais chez eux ou sur
le trajet de la mairie l'albanais
propose d'instaurer une réunion
quotidienne avec les serbes afin de
régler tout ça mais l'employé albanaise
est tenace elle nous emmène à son bureau
elle a des preuves que les serbes encore
ici ont collaboré avec les forces
dit-elle du monstre de belgrade
des preuves une photo du maire adjoint
en uniforme paru pendant les
bombardements dans une revue servent de
pristina pour elle ils doivent tous
partir
regroupés au premier étage les serbes
raconte que la municipalité a au
contraire tout tenté pour éviter les
règlements de comptes dans la ville
qu'après stinat peu de maisons brûlées
mais que les albanais ont quand même
tout cas c'est en entrant ici
les serbes se disent prêts à reprendre
le travail mais welt une présence
constante de la kfor
cette fois ci ils resteront enfermés
dans cette pièce toute la journée et
selon le hcr 685000 réfugiés albanais
sont déjà entrés au kosovo mais dans le
même temps disent les autorités
orthodoxe 130 mille serbes sur les deux
cent mille que compte le peu de la
province ont déjà fui le pays les
tziganes par également ce sont
maintenant les nouveaux réfugiés compte
accueillir les autorités italiennes
reportage dans le camp ne pas léser près
de bari alain de chalon
le camp est toujours le même un peu
mieux organisées on a mis les caravanes
à l'ombre on a compris des toilettes une
immense tente réfectoire lente il est ce
qu'en a vu passer toutes les misères des
balkans d'abord les albanais d'albanie
fuyant les émeutes dans leur pays
puis ceux du kosovo fuyant les serbes et
maintenant les gitans du même kosovo
les roms comme on les appelle là-bas
fuyant les victimes des bourreaux
d'aujourd'hui si l'on en croit le récit
mais l'autre d'état les albanais m'ont
dit tu as deux minutes pour quitter ta
maison où on tue des enfants et on brûle
tout va-t'en va-t'en vous n'avez rien à
faire au kosovo vous les roms laissez
vous êtes avec les albanais et quand les
albanais sont rentrés d'albanie d'un
calice de partout où il était réfugié
ils nous ont dit vous êtes avec les
serbes mais nous sommes des musulmans il
nous n'avons jamais été contre les
albums nous sommes leurs frères dans
l'islam ils arrivent par petits groupes
via la serbie et le monténégro par les
mêmes filières mafieuses qui hier les
albanais à 10000 francs le passage en
italie ils recevront ipso facto le
statut de réfugié politique
nomade par excellence il ne voit pas le
kosovo comme leur terre cette ethnie et
des roms ne veux pas retourner maison va
donner mais veut rester en italie ou en
europe serait d'avoir un travail une
maison en allemagne on chez de la
famille voilà pourquoi la cabine
téléphonique est le centre névralgique
du camp là où s'organisent les
regroupements familiaux
quand ce n'est pas la nurserie car le
camp a aussi connu un heureux événement
l'irak a procédé aujourd'hui aux
obsèques de 17 civils tués dans un raid
américain sur la province chiite de
nadjaf au sud du pays selon les
autorités irakiennes c'est le raid le
plus meurtrier depuis la campagne de
frappes aériennes
engagé en décembre dernier aux états
unis le premier ministre israélien ehud
barak poursuit ses entretiens avec le
président clinton il s'agit pour les
deux hommes de relancer le processus de
paix monsieur barack se donne quinze
mois pour cela à paris son ambassadeur
annoncé qu'il effectuerait une visite
spéciale en france après les états unis
monsieur barak doit en effet se rendre à
londres et madrid mais sans passer par
paris
en france les nuages et une légère brise
ont permis à l'île de france et au sud
est de voir leur situation s'améliorer
du point de vue de la pollution après un
week-end assez pénible la qualité de
l'air a progressé à paris on a pourtant
pris des mesures pour limiter la vitesse
des automobilistes
reportage de gérad hilde d'alban morenas
et de jean-louis mollahs un soleil de
plomb une circulation très dense
toutes les conditions étaient réunies
pour que la pollution refasse son
apparition hier le niveau 2 a été
atteint en ile de france
la préfecture de police de paris a donc
immédiatement déclenché une procédure
d'information du grand public mais
également de répression de nombreux
contrôles antipollution ont été mises en
place aujourd'hui dans la capitale des
contrôles plutôt bien accepté
certaines personnes vont nous disent que
quand même c'est bien ce qu'ont fait
malgré lamendin ça les dérange pas
spécialement d'être verbalisé de
certains sont surpris que leurs
véhicules polluent bon certaines
voitures viennent de passer le contrôle
technique ou où les voitures sont
relativement bien entretenus par leurs
propriétaires des propriétaires qu'ils
connaissent les effets néfastes de la
voiture sur la qualité de l'air mais qui
avoue ne pas pouvoir se passer de leur
véhicule pour dire à venir
au musée vêtue d'un micro et
et pour vous exposer autres mesures la
réduction de 20 km/heure de la vitesse
autorisée sur les grands axes de la
capitale
mais finalement c'est la météo qui
décide en début d'après-midi un léger
vent a permis une amélioration de la
situation qui reste précaire
c'est vrai que pour les jours qui
viennent si le beau temps se maintient
et que le vent se calme et avec des
températures avoisinant les 30 degrés ou
au delà les risques sont inconnues
d'avoir des épisodes de forte pollution
photochimique
certains semblent pourtant avoir déjà
trouvé la solution il ne risque ni
contravention ni de polluer la guerre
commerciale entre l'europe et les états
unis pour protester contre
l'interdiction européenne d'importer du
boeuf aux hormones les etats unis
imposent des taxes à 100% sur tout un
ensemble de produits européens
les fleurons français que sont le
roquefort le foie gras la moutarde et
même les truffes sont dans le
collimateur eric mézil
le 14 juillet dernier jacques chirac lui
même avait tenu à rassurer le
consommateur français
pour ce qui concerne le boeuf aux
hormones que nous n'importons pas et que
nous n'importerons pas en europe est une
décision d'ailleurs communautaire s'est
dit est clairement le boeuf aux hormones
américain ne passera pas par l'europe
mais les états unis et le canada ne
l'entendent pas de cette oreille
dan glickman le ministre américain de
l'agriculture avait rencontré il ya
quelques semaines son homologue français
jean glavany pour parvenir à un accord
peine perdue car les américains se
sentent en position de force depuis que
l'organisation mondiale du commerce leur
a donné raison à partir du 29 juillet
prochain le port le boeuf mais aussi des
produits symboliques comme le foie gras
ou la truffe seront taxés à 100%
laura leurs prix en amérique du nord une
liste qui pourrait s'allonger
tant que le montant des pénalités n'a
pas atteint les 830 millions de francs
fixé par l'om c'est les syndicats
agricoles appellent au boycott
nous lançons ce boycott pour que
l'ensemble des consommateurs qui
prennent un risque en consommant de la
viande aux hormones et bien réagi ce
parce que nous n'acceptons pas que les
américains et inondent notre marché avec
de la viande aux ordres 90 % de la
viande produite aux états unis est fait
à base d'hormones
le ministre de l'agriculture on ne
désespère pas de trouver un terrain
d'entente
d'autant que les américains n'ont pas
sanctionné les produits les plus
exportés comme l'eau minérale
enfin l'europe entend bien prouver avant
la fin de l'année que les hormones sont
bien toxiques pour la santé
une autre guerre c mais cette fois entre
les deux géants français du pétrole et
de la chimie elf et total fina ce qui
est sûr c'est que les deux groupes vont
fusionner mais qui va l'emporter c'est
une autre histoire
après l'offre publique des changes de
total sur elf c'est aujourd'hui elf
aquitaine qui répliquent avec une offre
concurrente les explications de hugo
plagnard ryad fronty et marie-laure
gendre sourire carnassier sous les
flashs
la proie est devenu prédateur ce matin
philippe jaffré le pdg d'elf est sorti
de son silence pour contrer l'offre de
rachat lancée par total final une contre
attaque menée par actionnaires interposé
car pour prendre le contrôle de son
concurrent
elle propose d'échanger trois actions
elf et 190 euros ce qui fait presque
1200 francs contre 5 titres total fina
l'offre est alléchante puisqu'elle
permettrait aux actionnaires d'empocher
une plus-value de 10%
mais pour philippe jaffré le projet
d'elf ne se limite pas un bon coup en
bourse
ce n'est donc ni une réplique ni une
surenchère c'est un autre projet
industriel fondé sur une autre vision
et c'est en fait un projet que nous
construisions depuis des années au sein
d'elf aquitaine
un projet de fusion qui pourrait aboutir
à la création de deux géants industriels
un groupe pétrolier est un groupe
chimique tous deux situés dans les cinq
premiers mondiaux
à défaut de pouvoir s'allier à un groupe
étranger ce que l'état toujours
actionnaires d'elf n'aurait pas accepté
philippe jaffré a opéré un virage à 180
degrés dans un communiqué total fina
relève avec ironie que le pdg d'elf
après avoir toujours rejeté le principe
de cette fusion on reconnaît maintenant
l'intérêt mais cela ne convainc pas les
analystes financiers qui voit dans le
projet d'elf d'autres motivations pour
l'expliquer
que le but ultime recherché par le
président-directeur général james est en
fait une négociation à 2 d'égal à égal
entre total et son groupe elf pour
discuter des conditions d'une chose
hi-fi gion faute d'accord entre les deux
groupes seront aux actionnaires de
trancher quant au gouvernement il n'a ce
soir pas encore réagi au projet de
philippe jaffré a strasbourg les
parlementaires européens préparent leur
séance inaugurale de demain ils devront
élire leur président qui pourrait être
une présidente on parle beaucoup de
l'udf nicole fontaine
mais aujourd'hui l'heure était à
l'installation pour les 626 députés dont
87 français dans ce tout nouveau
bâtiment qui d'inaugurer dans lequel les
ont bien du mal à se retrouver reportage
d'albon nicosie et de patrie schumacher
il s'appelle bernard poignant tribune
diplomatique c'est pas moi non coupable
les cartes de votes pour la france
maire socialiste de quimper nouvel élu
député européen il est pour l'instant
surtout complètement perdu remarquez il
n'est pas seul
ainsi à errer dans les couloirs du tout
nouveau parlement européen
première préoccupation retirer sa carte
de vote pour le scrutin de demain je
vais l'utiliser pour la première fois en
votant pour mario soares comme lui pour
les 87 élus français et leur entourage
la journée un petit côté chasse aux
trésors assez réjouissant point un plan
ça fait penser un peu aux jeux de piste
vous savez quand on les scouts et quand
on distribue à me plaindre comme ça et
puis il faut arriver il ya des flèches
et à l'ailé il ya des endroits cachés
pour trouver retour sur bernard poignant
qui est maintenant à la recherche de son
bureau
huit étages plus haut chaque eurodéputé
disposera d'une de ces cellules pour
tours qui 12 m² avec salle de bains
banquette lit et téléviseurs
de quoi appréhender les séances
nocturnes ce soir ce sont les premières
réunions de groupe jean saint-josse et
les chasseurs tentent avec leurs amis
néerlandais d'adopter une attitude
commune pour le vote de demain
moi j'ai préféré m'abstenir mais je suis
pas tout seul donc on va négocier
bernard poignant enfin pris place au
milieu de ses collègues socialistes il a
un bureau une carte de vote il est
heureux et prêts pour la séance plénière
demain
guy canivet le nouveau président de la
cour de cassation a été installé
officiellement dans ses fonctions cet
après midi une audience solennelle en
présence de jacques chirac et
d'elisabeth guigou guy canivet à 55 ans
il était nommé le 2 juillet en
remplacement de pierre truche il devient
le plus jeune magistrat accéder à ce
poste qui devrait donc occuper jusqu'à
sa retraite c'est à dire dans une
douzaine d'années dans l' enquête sur
les hlm de paris jean tiberi a été
entendu aujourd'hui par le juge
d'instruction eric halphen une audition
très discrète au tribunal de créteil
une drôle d'affaires de contrefaçon à
l'aéroport d'orly les douaniers ont
saisi plus d'une tonne de matériel
médical des tensiomètres en provenance
de chine est soi-disant de la marque
pentax mais en tout cas des outils
dangereux alain du bas et m'a dit dis
ouah c'est la première prise de matériel
médical contrefaits réalisé en france
la contrefaçon n'est plus réservé aux
grandes marques de produits de luxe a
dans ses cartons 2000 tensiomètre
saisies par les douaniers français
analyse des documents afférentes à la
réglementation du commerce extérieur ont
prouvé malgré le fait que sur ce
matériel et on le voit très
distinctement cela soit marqué japan les
documents relatifs à la réglementation
du commerce extérieur ils nous ont
apporté la preuve tangible que cela
venait effectivement de chine et non pas
du japon c'est contre soissons était
destinée au marché européen
mais pour les utilisateurs il y un
risque en fait elles peuvent se
retrouver avec un arrêt cardiaque dû à
une hypertension parce que tout
simplement ils n'auront pas su utiliser
de mode d'emploi qui est d'ailleurs très
succinct pour pouvoir se surveiller
le mode d'emploi est grossièrement
scanner risée la pochette de mauvaise
qualité et sans inscription
le comble la firme pentax n'a jamais
fabriqué ce matériel l'essentiel des
métiers de pentax est centré autour de
l'optique s'agisse d'appareils photos
d'endoscopes d'appareils de taupo
mettrie d'objectifs de surveillance mais
en aucun cas ce type de matériel n'est
fabriqué par pentax la sphère été
transmise au tribunal de créteil pour
essayer de remonter la filière des
trafiquants pour sa journée de repos à
la veille des pyrénées le tour de france
99 vient de connaître sa première
exclusion c'est le champion de belgique
ludo dierckxsens vainqueur de la 11e
étape qui a reconnu lors d'un contrôle
avoir recours à des corticoïdes
il s'agissait de soigner un genou malade
dire scène ça a été exclu du tour par
son équipe le contrôle lui s'étaient
avérés négatifs florent gautreau et
philippe deslandes un bruit qui court
une rumeur qui enfle et enfin une
information qui se confirme à l'équipe
italienne lampre et son directeur
sportif qui est trop algérie viennent
d'exclure le belge ludo dierckxsens pour
usage de corticoïdes
avant même la décision de la commission
médicale de l'ue s'est dit le médecin de
l'équipe lampre fabio d'haïti a informé
le coureur ludo dierckxsens de sa
suspension de toute compétition à titre
préventif et ce pour une période
indéterminée
ludo dierckxsens vainqueur à
saint-etienne jeudi n'a pas été contrôlé
positif à l'issue de l'étape en revanche
à l'occasion de ce contrôle
il a avoué avoir fait usage plusieurs
semaines auparavant de synacthène un
médicament contenant des corticoïdes
possédait-il une prescription médicale
mystère le médecin de l'équipe lampre
affirme qu'il n'a pas fourni de
certificats et que le champion de
belgique s'est soigné tout seul
en clair l'équipe italienne est en train
de lâcher son coureur pour sauver son
image une image pourtant déjà écornée
depuis le mois de juin le directeur
sportif pietro algérie et son adjoint
avaient été mises en examen pour
distribution de produits dangereux pour
la santé
un coureur s'en va un autre repart au
combat
lance armstrong avait choisi la journée
de repos pour s'exprimer pendant une
heure devant les journalistes son
objectif faire taire les rumeurs de
dopage qui entoure son surprenant
parcours depuis dix jours au canada
que puis-je y faire j'ai clamé mon
innocence
j'ai déjà dit à tout le monde que
j'avais vécu des choses autrement plus
grave est que j'avais frôlé la mort je
ne suis pas fou mais c'est vrai que ces
rumeurs me perturbe un coureur vainqueur
d'étape exclut par sa propre équipe le
maillot jaune obligé de se justifier
quant à ses performances des contrôles
antidopage dont on conteste l'efficacité
le tour de france sort à nouveau
ébranlée de cette journée de repos à
saint gaudens et demain c'est donc la
première étape des pyrénées la haute
couture c'est le temps des collections
automne hiver avec aujourd'hui ungaro
sherer ted lapidus
l'occasion pour ce film et elle et
valérie le cadre de répondre à une
question mais à quoi sert vraiment la
haute couture quand on sait que les
ventes de ces fabuleuses robes des
défilés sont quasi inexistantes
nous sommes chez l'une des plus petites
maisons de couture de paris lapidus fils
olivier a succédé à son père ted il ya
tout juste dix ans il est dans le giron
du groupe de parfums bogarde ici comme
dans la plupart des départements haute
couture on ne vend que très peu de robe
celle-ci clou de la collection est aussi
la plus chère
e
j'ai pas le prix à vue de nez c'est au
franc offrant près c'est l'europe qui va
tourner avec 220 mille francs je pense à
peu près 200 privilégiés viva entre les
émirats arabes et les états unis
estime-t-on ont les moyens de craquer
alors qu'au lendemain de la guerre et
même plus d'une décennie plus tard la
couture compter plusieurs milliers de
clientes comme celles venues ici
assister au second défilé d'un jeune
homme plein de talent il saint laurent à
l'époque le prêt-à-porter n'existait
presque par la plupart des femmes
s'habillent et sur mesure
faute de clients la couture a failli
périr avec le siècle c'était avant son
lifting réussi l'arrivée d'un souffle
frais avec mugler ou jean paul gaultier
galliano chez dior et alexander mcqueen
pour givenchy
désormais les maisons de 100 cash plus
les défilés de couture ne sert ce que
leur prestige qui par ricochet rejaillit
sur les produits que tout le monde peut
s'offrir la culture elle est assise ou
pardon à d'orsay au prêt à porter ou au
parfum mais elle ne peut pas vivre seul
répertorié dans ses cahiers la revue de
presse des défilés les plus médiatisés
génère 5 à 600 articles et reportages
dans le monde entier en à peine une
semaine
ici on calcule très précisément ce que
rapporte un défilé à la marque
nous on va à partir de l'ensemble de
leurs coupures chiffre est ce que ça va
leur rapporter en termes d'équivalent
coup publicitaire
donc finalement s'il avait dû faire de
la pub à partir de l'ensemble de ses
boucs combien aurait-il dû investir
voilà la problématique à laquelle on
ouvre leur permet de répondre le record
de rentabilité a été atteint en 95 avec
la présentation show de thierry mugler
16 millions de francs investis 85
millions de retombées en équivalent pub
ce soir dur fera peut-être monter les
enchères
la maison qui se lancent régulièrement
dans des superproductions comme l'inde a
mis en garde samedi les file rend très
grande pompe au château de versailles
c'est le prix à payer pour que cette
grille vieille dessus de 50 en face
toujours rêver les canadiens ont
réinventé le pédalo ils appellent ça du
surf bike de la bicyclette nautique mais
dans le pas de calais près de saint-omer
c'est l'occasion de découvrir autrement
les fameux marais qui se trouve une idée
originale et facilement transposable à
de mourgues et patrick bource temps
un zeste et de bicyclettes un soupçon de
planche à voile quelques grammes de
pédalos voilà un drôle d'engin tout
nouveau pour partir à la découverte du
marais et de ses habitants en fait je
nous vois mis en marche avant plus
habitué aux bateaux à moteur un urgent
louis et matthieu sont venus en famille
prêt à tenter une nouvelle expérience
ouais il faut trouver l'équilibré
le sort vaille que ça se conduit un peu
comme un vélo à part que 20 ans une fois
l'équilibré trouvé sans bruit au fil de
l'eau vitesse de croisière 6 km heure
cela permet de se balader sans faire de
bruit on est vraiment dans la nature on
entend les oiseaux
beaucoup d'oiseaux et puis on est à
hauteur on est un auteur se change par
rapport à bien regarder les canadiens et
les salaires sont là les oeufs ne sauve
pas on est carrément fait partie
vraiment de du paysage quoi de nez dans
l'ana dessus
pierre à apporter le surf bike du canada
sportif accompli aventuriers il reste
maintenant pour sa petite reine d'autres
horizons
ces 100 appareils wi qui nous permettra
d'avoir des activités familiales et
sportives également c'est parce qu'on
peut on peut faire des reines avec un
peu on peut ajouter entre guillemets à
nouveau sport voir pourquoi toi aux jeux
olympiques par la suite
nous partons maintenant pour beaune et
son festival de musique baroque c'est sa
17e édition cette année avec au
programme quatre opéras on y retrouve
jordi savall l'auteur de la musique de
tous les matins du monde qui recompose
des musiques anciennes et les
interprètes sur les instruments d'époque
marie-josée joue en évinçant
bouffartigue du baroque mais au sens
large du terme car son 17e cru le
festival international de musique
baroque de beaune accueille aussi bien
les élèves de l'académie d'été de
musique que mozart haendel et bach ou
encore les musiciens anonyme du xiiie
siècle profane jeu sacré la soirée sera
médiévale comme les célèbres hospices où
l'on soigné les pauvres après la guerre
de cent ans et qui sert aujourd'hui de
cadre aux opéras baroques du festival le
chef catalan jordi savall a choisi lui
la basilique romane pour faire découvrir
avec son orchestre espérions 20
l'espagne des trois cultures juive
chrétienne et musulmane au moyen âge
depuis 30 ans jordi savall s'emploie à
dénicher recomposer des musiques
d'anciennes sa femme la soprano
montserrat figueras les choses
nous sommes plutôt des architectes
nouveau que nous refaisons larchitecture
décès musique en leur mettant en place
aujourd'hui dans ce concept nous faisons
nous respectons nous retrouvons les
partitions nous essayons de trouver des
sons les couleurs les assumant nous
essayons de reconstruire aussi l'ailé
manière de chanter de jouer les
augmentations mais une partie importante
de la musique nous faisons et les crée
aujourd'hui chez les savanes est la
musique ancienne c'est aussi une affaire
de famille
ariana leur fille a choisi leur peu
médiévale pour les accompagner c'est la
première fois en concert il ya une
complicité qu'elle est très belle pas
seulement comme famille s'il n'en suis
qu'aux musiciens et ça c'est vraiment
un cadeau
l'espace d'un soir boon a écouté ses
chants de femmes ces cris d'amour écoute
de rhodes ou d'istanbul
le festival baroque avec un grand ouvert
voilà c'est bientôt la fin de cette
édition je vous en rappelle le principal
titre
aux états unis il n'y a maintenant plus
d'espoir de retrouver de jfk junior son
épouse et sa belle soeur encore en vie
les recherches se sont intensifiées pour
tenter de retrouver leurs corps pendant
que les drapeaux sont en berne à yanis
porte dans ce que l'on appelle le clan
kennedy dans un instant la météo
présentée par isabelle martinet à 20h55
jeux sans frontières animé par nelson
monfort et fabienne égal 22h50 henry 5
la pièce en cinq actes 1,8 de william
shakespeare
présentée au festival d'avignon demain à
7h50 dans les 4 vérités marie pierre
farkas recevra nicole fontaine
vice-président de sortante du parlement
européen est présidente possible de la
future assemblée
à 13 heures carole gaessler et rachid
arhab évidemment et à 20 heures pour le
plaisir de vous retrouver
je vous souhaite une bonne soirée sur
france 2 bien sûr
à